I basically got ratioed on Twitter for
saying that the moon landing happened
that's how bad things have gotten
looking at a conspiracy theory very
first thing you should ask yourself is
how many people would need to be
involved for it to work and if the
answer is that a relatively small number
of highlevel powerful people would have
to be involved then your theory at least
has a chance of passing the initial
smell
test but if the answer is that the
conspiracy would necessitate the close
cooperation and secrecy of thousands of
people across multiple agencies and
institutions then you're going to have
to meet a very very high evidentiary bar
to make your theory even slightly
credible if they were going to go
through all this trouble to to fake the
pictures why would they neglect to add
stars to the sky like wouldn't that be
the first thing you do if you were
faking a picture of outer space why
would they pretend the moon has wind as
many people have argued to me over the
weekend if we really landed on the moon
then why haven't we ever gone back well
the first answer is that we did